dekel déconfinement la question du
retour au travail de l'action justice de
la cgt contre une usine de renault aux
propositions chocs de l'institut
montaigne pour rebondir
les vieilles querelles ressurgissent in
que le monde d'après n'est peut-être pas
pour tout de suite
en attendant devront nous dire adieu aux
congés payés ou rtt faudra-t-il
travailler plus pour gagner moins
on voit ça tout de suite avec notre
économie jacques sapir que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui encore via skype a bon soit
en rack vous vous êtes des cons filet
avec prudence on espère oui c'est fanny
bonjour avec les gestes barrières bien
entendu alors jacques ce déconfinement
on en parle c'est donc travailler plus
pour gagner moins
oui c'est la grande question du moment
stéphanie alors effectivement à écouter
ou l'institut montaigne ou encore
christian jacob le patron des
républicains
on peut penser que c'est ce qui nous
attend et en même temps vous voyez moi
aussi j'ai été contaminé par notre
président donc et en même temps nous
avons cette action en justice intentée
par la cgt qui a fait fermer l'usiné
renault de sandouville
alors tout ça a bien effectivement un
petit goût du monde d'avant dans le
monde d'après alors jacques commençons
d'abord par l'action de la cgt
comment peut-on faire faire fermer une
usine alors qu'on les rouvre un peu
partout bien stéphanie la cgt a
considéré que et la justice d'ailleurs
sur ce point lui a donné raison que les
conditions techniquement n'avaient pas
été réunies dans cette reprise de
l'activité chez renault alors au delà
d'un conflit entre syndicats
on voit très bien qu'il ya un conflit
entre la cgt et la cfdt compliqué donc
tout à fait réelle ya en réalité un
problème qui est plus profond en 2017 et
la ministre du travail madame muriel
pénicaud dans sa réforme du code du
travail a décidé de remplacer les divers
comités existants dans les entreprises
par des comités sociaux économiques
rappellent les 16e et c 'est ce était
censée fusionner alors à la fois les
anciens délégués du personnel
les comités d'hygiène et de sécurité et
le comité d'entreprise cette réforme
très concrètement a abouti à diminuer le
poids des représentants du personnel
dans l'entreprise et dans le cas de
renault
on peut penser que si le comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité avait toujours
existé
on aurait un meilleur cadre pour la
discussion et londres est peut-être pu
éviter d'en arriver à une action en
justice
voyez c'est un exemple ou la réforme du
code du travail
loin d'améliorer le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise l'a en réalité beaucoup
compliqué alors jacquet allant plus loin
ce que propose au contraire à l'institut
montaigne même si c'est douloureux
évidemment à ce que cela ne ne s'impose
pas dans la situation actuelle
stéphanie oui nous sommes évidemment
dans une situation exceptionnelle
personne ne le nie le pib qui mesure la
richesse nationale va reculer d'environ
10 % peut-être plus sur l'ensemble de
l'année et personne ne nie non plus que
le plus dur soit à venir et qui pourrait
y avoir une vague de fumeurs au second
semestre
mais qu'est ce que propose réellement
l'institut mantel alors tout d'abord il
veut augmenter le temps de travail pour
rattraper le temps perdu lors du
confinement bon or pour cela il dit et
là de ce consulat je cite le rapport le
principal frein aujourd'hui à
l'augmentation du temps de travail
réside dont le surcoût que représente
l'accroissement du temps de travail pour
les entreprises
aujourd'hui la loi impose une majoration
aussi bien pour les heures
supplémentaires que pour les rachats des
jours de rtt
ce qui veut dire que l'institut mérieux
de monteils veut faire sauter le plafond
des heures supplémentaires et modifier
leurs rémunérations mais aussi
s'attaquer au principe des rtt et des 35
heures est sur les 35 heures vrai qu'on
n'est pas le seul à le dire oui tout à
fait c'est fini christian jacob le
président des républicains a déclaré
lundi 11 mai donc il ya quelques jours
qu'il fallait sortir de ce qu'il appelle
le carcan des 35 heures il n'est pas le
premier et il n'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs à tenir ce genre de discours
seulement voilà quand on sait que les
français travaillent en réalité non
35 heures mais 38 heures 10 on voit que
ce à quoi s'attaque christian jacob
c'est au paiement des heures
supplémentaires
en fait la volonté de réformer le
système des 35 heures permettrait aux
entreprises de payer les 38 heures 10
supplémentaires que font en moyenne les
salariés au même tarif que les heures
précédentes
c'est donc une mesure qui entraînerait
une baisse des rémunérations
bref c'est le travailler plus pour
gagner moins
alors jacques elle désolée c'est mon
rôle là je reviens à la charge tout de
même parce que ce n'est pas nécessaire
aujourd'hui actuellement sollicité fanny
si nous étions dans une situation de
plein emploi
on pourrait peut-être en discuter selon
le chômage est important en france et
d'ailleurs il va augmenter dans les
semaines qui viennent vous prenez tout
simplement les catégories a aidé de pôle
emploi c'est les gens qui sont sans
emploi demandeurs d'emploi sans emploi
nous avons d'ores et déjà 3,6 millions
de personnes sans emploi
et si on y ajoute les 770 milles
personnes qui sont employées pour moins
d'un mi-temps autrement dit moins de 20
heures par semaine contre leur volonté
on obtient 4,3 millions de personnes qui
constitue en réalité les chômeurs réels
alors même si on ne prend en compte que
les personnes qui sont strictement sans
emploi cela reste au-dessus des 11%
on le voit par exemple sur le tableau
qui est ici présentées au louvre que
cela peu de sens de demander à ceux qui
travaillent de travailler plus
quand il ya tant de personnes qui
recherchent un emploi c'est même en
réalité assez incohérent dans la
situation actuelle
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par
l'aja caler votre arrière pensée on vous
connaît alors bon arrière pensée
stéphanie sait que admettons que l'on
applique les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne ou celle de
christian jacob
qu'est-ce qui se passe la rémunération
des personnes employées besré puisque
c'est explicitement ce que veut
l'institut montaigne les heures
supplémentaires ne seraient plus
rémunérés au tarif normal et une partie
des rtt ne serait plus compensés et rien
n'empêcherait par ailleurs les
entreprises de faire travailler les gens
42 heures voire plus il n'y aurait donc
plus aucun effet d'appel sur les
chômeurs mais en plus la demande toutes
choses égales par ailleurs
vestri et en quoi cette baisse de la
demande serait un problème c'est que la
baisse de la demande
elle se cumuleraient elle se cumulera en
réalité avec la volonté et des ménages
d'épargné plus stéphanie les chansons
inquiet il faut les comprendre
le confinement a été un choc
psychologique majeur pour la majorité de
la population
si on regarde la chine et c'est
intéressant parce que la chine cd
confiné avant nous seuls les plus riches
ont repris leur consommation d'avant
l'épidémie les classes moyennes et
moyennes inférieures elles ont réduit
leur consommation
en réalité pour augmenter leur épargne
or si la demande baisse le niveau de
l'économie
baisse aussi d'autant plus qu'il est
illusoire de penser que dans une
situation mondiale de crise
il pourrait y avoir une forte demande
extérieure pour nos exportations
et c'est là que l'on voit se dessiner le
risque de tsunami du chômage vous savez
on considère que ce dernier augmentera
probablement de 500000 personnes d'ici
au début de cet automne seulement en cas
de crise massive de la demande nous
pourrions bien dépasser le million de
chômeurs voire peut-être même atteindre
les 2 millions de chômeurs en plus isaac
c'est pour cette raison que vous
n'approuvez pas les recommandations de
l'institut montaigne
et oui c'est fini observez la différence
entre la situation post confinement et
celle de l'après guerre en 1945 c'est
que l'appareil de production est intacte
dans une france en ruines ce qui était
le cas en 1945 le fameux retrouve chez
vos mains de maurice thorez
le dirigeant communiste pouvait
parfaitement se comprendre lui
aujourd'hui la question est bien plus
celle de la demande
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de la demande
des ménages ou qu'il s'agisse de la
demande publique
la véritable question qui se pose n'est
pas c'est du travail mais celle de la
relance
or et il faut quand même en parler
les projets actuels du gouvernement sont
complètement inadéquat sur ce point
prenons le prenons note d'abord le plan
relance le prendre le rôle de relance ne
sera annoncé qu'en septembre prochain
c'est beaucoup trop tard il risque d'y
avoir d'ici la fin du mois d'août un
massacre dans les entreprises en
particulier dans les petites entreprises
durant cet été il faudrait si on était
raisonnable que ce plan soit annoncée
dès la mi juin au 1er juillet au plus
tard et puis les sommes que veut engager
le gouvernement sont décidément trop
faible alors bruno le maire parle
beaucoup des 110 milliards de prêts vu
se bat
ce qu'ils oublient de dire est ce qu'on
oublie en règle générale c'est que il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent frais dans
ses 110 milliards en fait qu'elle n'a
pas plus de 45 milliards
au mieux il faudrait au moins le double
de cette somme peut être même le triple
si on veut qu'une demande intérieure
solide et durable se substitue à la
demande étrangère qui elle alors ça on
en est sûr sera défaut alors en
conclusion jacques verrier que
l'institut montaigne se trompe de cible
tout à fait stéphanie tout à fait et
c'est bien ça le problème
ils raisonnent comme si on était face à
d'immenses destructions matérielles ou
alors comme si on manquait de
travailleurs seulement nous ne sommes
pas confrontés à l'une de ces deux
situations
du fait du chômage c'est en réalité l'un
vers ce qui se passe il faut trouver du
travail pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
en plus particulièrement pour tous ceux
qui vont perdre le la du fait des
conséquences de confinement dans ce
contexte c'est une
c'est une politique de demandes qu'il
faut faire et pas une politique de
l'offre parce que cette politique de
l'offre qui est enrayé une caricature de
politique de l'offre est non seulement
inadéquate mais pourrait même contribuer
à aggraver de manière tout à fait
considérable la crise économique
allons vivre dans les prochains mois
merci jacques sapir pour cet édito échos
qui en fera réfléchir plus d'un
mir